CAROLINA.
WE'LL TALK ABOUT THAT.
EVEN THOUGH THE PANDEMIC IS
OVER.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID IT WAS
BUT FIRST, IT'S NOT 2020 ANYMORE
AND PRESIDENT BIDEN IS OUT OF
HIS BASEMENT CAMPAIGN FOR
DEMOCRATS AHEAD OF THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS IN 24 DAYS.
THE BIDEN CHOW DOWN ON DONUTS HE
REVEALED HIS NEW TACTIC TO LIE
TO VOTERS BY CLAIMING THE
REPUBLICANS WILL CAUSE INFLATION
TO GO UP IF THEY WIN.
>> THE COMES TIME TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT INFLATION.
>> REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS WHO
SAY NO.
>> REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS SAID
NO.
>> THE PRICES WILL GO UP AS WELL
INFLATION.
>> INFLATION WILL GO UP NOT
DOWN.
>> BIDEN HAS BEEN SPIN THE BAD
NEWS ABOUT THE ECONOMY INFLATION
HITTING 8.2% IN DECEMBER, HE'S
GRUMBLING.
HE WON'T SAY INVASION SEARCHED
SINCE HE ENTERED THE WHITE HOUSE
WAGE INCREASES HAVEN'T KEPT UP.
THE NATIONAL REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSIONAL SPOKESPERSON
SAYING EVERY AMERICAN IS DEALING
WITH OUT-OF-CONTROL PRICE HIKES
LIKE DEMOCRATS RECKLESS
SPENDING, PULL AFTER SHOWS
INFLATION IS THE NUMBER ONE
ISSUE HEADING INTO THE MIDTERMS
AND THE QUESTION TONIGHT, IS
BIDEN CAMPAIGN FOR DEMOCRAT
CANDIDATES HELPING SWAY DEMOCRAT
VOTERS?
POLL SHOWS NEARLY A QUARTER OF
DEMOCRAT VOTERS DISAPPROVE OF
BIDEN'S PERFORMANCE AS RESIDENT.
TYRUS, ACCORDING TO PRESIDENT
BIDEN, HE SAYS IT SIMPLE.
IF REPUBLICANS WIN MIDTERM,
INFLATION AND PRICES WILL GO UP
BUT THINGS LOOK PRETTY BAD RIGHT
NOW.
FAMILIES ARE GOING INTO THE
HOLIDAY SEASON TRAVELING LESS,
DOING LESS SOCIAL ACTIVITIES
BECAUSE THEY NEED TO PAY FOR
UTILITIES.
FROM THE ENERGY INFORMATION
ADMINISTRATION, WHICH ARE FUEL
OUTLOOK, THEY SHOW INCREASED FOR
NATURAL GAS, HEATING OIL,
ELECTRICITY AND PROPANE ARE
GOING TO INCREASE THIS WINTER.
AMERICANS ARE GOING TO STRUGGLE.
>> LET'S START FROM THE TOP.
AFTER BEING SIMPLE, I LOVE HE
SAID WHEN IT COMES TIME TO FIX
INFLATION.
[LAUGHTER]
WHAT?
SO YOU HAVEN'T BEEN?
ACCORDING TO ALL THESE THINGS
YOU GIVE YOURSELF A PRAISE SO HE
HASN'T EVEN STARTED GET.
AND PRESIDENT IS RIGHT.
WHEN THE REPUBLICANS TAKE THE
HOUSE, INFLATION WILL BE THROUGH
THE ROOF AND IN TROUBLE BECAUSE
JUST BECAUSE THEY GET VOTED IN
23 DAYS IT WILL GET TIME THEY
GET INTO OFFICE AND DEBACLE THE
MESS SO IS 1000% TELLING THE
TRUTH -- KIND OF.
>> TYRUS SAYS PRESIDENT BIDEN IS
TELLING THE TRUTH.
BUT AMERICANS ARE NOT FOOLS
THOUGH INFLATION IS SIX TIMES
WHAT WAS TWO YEARS AGO.
I HEARD YOU ON FOXBUSINESS THE
OTHER DAY SAYING BIDEN'S
POLICIES DIRECTLY RESULTED IN
THE PRICES THAT HAVE GONE UP YET
WE HEAR PRESIDENT BIDEN SAYING
WE CAN'T LET REPUBLICANS WHEN
MIDTERMS BECAUSE EVERYTHING I'M
DOING JANUARY IS THE MAGIC
MONTH, IT'S ALL GOING TO GET
FIXED.
>> IT'S SO BORING WE WIN BECAUSE
A LOT OF WHAT WE'VE DONE DOESN'T
KICK IN UNTIL JANUARY SO PEOPLE
DON'T EVEN KNOW IT YET.
>> THAT'S LIKE THE BIGGEST CON
IN THE WORLD, IT'S BAD ENOUGH
THE LIGHT AT EVERY TURN AND THEY
WERE COMPLETELY DENYING THIS
EVEN EXISTED BUT AS IT TURNS OUT
EVEN INDEPENDENT AND DEMOCRATS
OF TO FILL CARS WITH GAS BUY
GROCERIES FOR THE FAMILIES AND
FEED THEIR FAMILIES SO THE LIES
NOT WORKING ANYMORE AND THEN
THEY COME UP WITH THIS ABSURD --
THEY CAN'T BLAME IT ON ANYBODY
ELSE IN TERMS OF POLITICAL
SYSTEM BECAUSE THEY CONTROL
EVERY LEVEL OF POWER IN
WASHINGTON.
THERE'S NO OTHER CORPORATE THERE
BUT THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
BLOWS MY MIND, THE FACT THAT
THESE ARE THE RESULTS, DIRECT
RESULT OF THEIR ADVERTISED
POLICIES ABOUT SPENDING AND GAS
PRICES AND THEY WANT PEOPLE TO
NOT BE ABLE TO AFFORD TO FILL
THEIR CARS WITH GAS BECAUSE THEY
THINK THE INTERNAL COMBUSTION
WILL AND HUMANITY.
I DON'T KNOW WHY THEY ARE NOT
SPIKING THE BALL, THEY SHOULD
TAKE CREDIT FOR THE FACT THAT
NOBODY CAN DRIVE A CAR ANYMORE.
THAT'S THEIR GOAL SO IT'S THIS
WEIRD THINK THEY'RE PLAYING
TRYING TO PRETEND LIKE IT'S
SOMEBODY ELSE'S FAULT AND HE
WASN'T THERE GOAL ALL ALONG BUT
IT WAS.
IN THEIR OWN WORDS.
>> IS A DECEPTIVE OR BLATANTLY
LYING TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE?
>> TOTALLY LYING AND AS THAT IS
THE POLLS LOOK GOING TO BE EVEN
WORSE, I DO BECAUSE INDEPENDENT
AND DEMOCRATS HAVE TO BUY
GROCERIES, TO.
THEY DON'T WANT THIS.
>> GOING INTO THE MIDTERMS,
INFLATION AND LIVING IS THE
NUMBER ONE THING ON THE BALLOT.
YOU CAN TALK ABOUT POLICIES ALL
DAY LONG BUT END OF THE DAY YOU
ARE GOING TO VOTE TO SEE IT IN
THEIR EVERYDAY LIFE.
>> YOU DON'T NEED POLICIES TO
OPEN UP YOUR BILLS.
EVERY TIME I OPEN UP MY BILLS I
SEE ALL THESE NEW HIRE CHARGES
SO I DON'T NEED A STACK TO SEE
WHAT'S GOING ON IN MY HOUSEHOLD
OR SEE WHAT'S GOING ON IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD TO SEE HOW
EXPENSIVE EVERYTHING IS.
>> HOW MANY TIMES HAVE YOU HEARD
SOMEBODY BEING AT THE GROCERY
STORE AND IT WAS $100 IN THERE
LOOKING DOWN LIKE WHAT DID I
BUY?
I'VE HEARD THAT SO MANY TIMES.
>> OR EVEN ABLE TO BUY IT IN
GENERAL BECAUSE BEFORE EVEN
WALKING IN THERE LIKE WE WANT TO
APOLOGIZE AHEAD OF TIME IF WE
DON'T HAVE WHAT YOU WANT BECAUSE
OF SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUES BUT I
WANT TO BRING UP THAT CHARLIE
SAID THIS ADMINISTRATION IS FLAT
OUT LYING TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
BIDEN HAS A WAY WITH WORDS, HE
REPEATS HIMSELF OVER AND OVER
BUT EVEN THE NEW YORK TIMES IS
POINTING OUT MAYBE SOME OF THE
THINGS HE'S SAYING OR
HALF-TRUTHS OR FLAT OUT LIES BUT
GENTLY HANDLING HIS MISTRUTHS.
>> THEY TREATED ALMOST AS IF
IT'S CHARMING BECAUSE THERE
HEADLINE WAS BIDEN'S STORYTELLER
SPENDS YARNS THAT OFTEN UNRAVEL.
EVERY PRESIDENT AND WE ALL KNOW
IT'S NOT A SURPRISE, FIND THE
TRUTH TO BE SOMEWHAT FLEXIBLE.
THAT'S THE WAY THEY WORK, I'M
NOT GIVING A PASS BUT WHAT'S
STRIKING IS THE WAY IT'S TREATED
DEPENDING ON THE PRESIDENT.
I WENT BACK TO DECEMBER 14,
2017, NEW YORK TIMES, AN OPINION
PIECE AND HE WAS THE HEADLINE --
TRUMPS LIES.
THEY DON'T CALL PRESIDENT BIDEN
A LIAR, THEY DON'T SAY IS
UNTRUTH OR NON- TRUTHS ARE LIES,
THEY MAKE THEM SOUND CUTE AND
ADORABLE AND AWAY HE SPENDS HIS
STORIES LIKE AN OLD
GRANDFATHERLY FIGURE BUT WHEN IT
CAME TO PRESIDENT TRUMP THEY
CALL HIM A LIAR AND THAT HE'S IN
PARTICULAR THEY LAID OUT DATE
FOR DATE JANUARY ALL THE WAY
THROUGH DECEMBER, EVERY FACT
CHECKED THEY HAD.
THE OTHER THING WHEN SOMEONE
CAME FORWARD WITH PRESIDENT
TRUMP AND SAID THAT TRUMP BE
TRUMP, THAT'S THE WAY HE DOES IT
AND THAT'S THE WAY IT WORKS,
THEY WERE DESTROYED.
HERE IS NOT WHAT HAPPENS WITH
THIS PRESIDENT'S OF THE WAY IT
IS TREATED IS INTERESTING AND
FRUSTRATING.
>> THE FIRST DAY IN OFFICE HE
STARTED THIS, CANCEL THE
PIPELINE.
HE CAUSED THE OIL PROBLEM, HE
DID IT AND BRIGHT BECAUSE IT
WOULD FORCE AMERICANS TO BUY
ELECTRONIC CARS JUST NO ONE TOLD
HIM DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH, THEY
WERE OVERPRICED AND THEY EXPLODE
IN FLOODS AND INFRASTRUCTURE IS
NOT BUILT FOR IT AND EVERYONE
LEFT THAT OUT WHILE HIGH-FIVING
TALKING ABOUT SAVING THE WORLD.
>> WE ARE FEELING A REPEAT
BECAUSE YOU HEARD CONVERSATIONS
AROUND OPEC BASED ON MIDTERM
DATES.
WE SAW THAT WITH COVID AND SAID
LET'S NOT CHANGE REOPENING
POLICIES UNTIL AFTER ELECTIONS
LIKE SOMEHOW POLITICS HAVE
ALWAYS INVADED EVERYDAY LIFE
THEY BECOME SO PERVASIVE PEOPLE
CAN DO ANYTHING WITHOUT
CIRCULATING AROUND MIDTERM
ELECTIONS OR ELECTIONS IN
GENERAL.
>> AND GOING BACK TO ELECTRIC
VEHICLES, IT'S PART OF THE
POLICY TO GET PEOPLE INTO
ELECTRIC VEHICLES AND WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE PRICES THAT WILL GO
UP THIS WINTER WEATHER HOME
HEATING OIL, GAS PRICES WHATEVER